good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday we are
past monday which is just so exciting
hey claude how are you doing
hello jackie i'm doing great i would say
i'm feeling euphoric i have been in
a euphoria
like
spiraling rabbit hole for literally 24
hours and i'm so annoyed like i tried to
time it perfectly there's only one
season in one episode so try to time it
perfectly
to talk about it on the toast and i have
like 20 minutes left in sunday night's
episode like i tried to finish it right
before we started but i couldn't you
could have asked for for the 20 minutes
because i could have asked for a recess
you could have asked for recess because
then you could have recapped and like
been with the kids and everything but
what is the verdict
okay the verdict is it's just like
really shocking because i feel like most
time i go into shows and i know what
they're about you know for the most part
and i thought this was a show about kids
in high school kids in high school like
doing drugs
yeah like you know having crazy
experiences experimenting with drugs
that's what i thought it was too
and like it is that but it's just way
more extreme than i would have thought
like and i'm not sure if it's an
accurate representation of what goes on
in high schools these days because i
have been out of high school for longer
than i care to admit but it was just
shocking like for me it was like a
cultural shock like are kids dressing
like this are kids throwing parties like
this where are all the parents why
aren't the cops called like when i was
in high school cops were always being
called and it's just like it's a lot for
me it's like a whole it's a learning
curve of what the younger generation is
up to so what's so extreme about it if
it's not if it's not just them doing
drugs
extreme drugs it's a lot of drugs it's a
lot of sex and i don't know if it's just
like you know we went to like a
religious high school like our kids
having this much sex at parties and
bathrooms with strangers who work at the
mall like
is that how it is i don't know
got it yeah i think our high school
experience was different from our fellow
high schoolers in general but then i
also wonder kids these days like with
the internet and access to everything
and also it's like you see those memes
of like what kids in high school look
like today versus what i looked like and
it's like they look like models and they
look so much older and
i think they're growing up even faster
yeah so i actually think it is like a
really accurate representation of what
goes on in the modern high school but
it's probably extreme just like anything
else that you've ever seen in hollywood
you know is an extreme so keep that in
mind there is just one thing about the
show that i found to be incredibly
shocking and it was just the amount of
penises
like hundreds like no lie like hundreds
of penises hundreds of high school
penises well that's the other weird
thing like we're supposed to believe i
mean jacob balorities and dia they're in
their 20s but we're supposed to believe
these are all juniors 17 year old kids
and i'm watching them [ __ ] like up
against doors like porn level stuff and
i'm like this feels bizarre because they
are supposed to be high schoolers minors
yeah that is bizarre
but i do i do like how they've kind of
flipped gender norms on their head
because you know when you watch like
raunchy tv shows or movies you see like
a thousand tits and like if you see
anything of a guy like you see one guy's
ass and i was like you know what you
have to show your penises and there
aren't that many boobs it's a nice
gender swap yeah so you're enjoying
you're enjoying the bounty of penises i
am and there is a whole storyline about
a girl who's a cam girl
and after watching um after recording
yesterday's episode and then watching
euphoria when one of the characters
becomes like a webcam girl it was kind
of um like a spiritual euphoric moment
for me does she say what kind of camera
she found to be best um it appeared as
though she was just using like her
built-in desktop computer oh well she's
a desktop so it's probably no sorry
built-in laptop computer got it okay you
know the laptop camera is was okay
yeah but i think this one is superior
you guys well she was just getting
started you know maybe it's like she
built more of a successful business she
would start investing in herself buying
different headphones equipment cords
cameras yeah i understand i feel like
that's literally all i did yesterday wow
well that's exciting i'm so glad that
you found something else to be a part of
and that you can recap the show because
so i mean everybody watches it so i'm
excited for the listeners can i tell you
why i really watched it because i was on
tick tock like yesterday and sunday and
everything was about euphoria and i was
like if i'm ever gonna watch a show it's
gonna get spoiled and they're like
cassie can't believe she did this i'm
like oh no what did she do and so i
really like in order to really be able
to continue my tic toc addiction i had
to open up another vein for euphoria
that makes sense
that does make sense so i'm
i'm i'm really happy for you like i
don't i know that you struggle to find
stuff to watch that like engages you and
this seems to be that so that's i was
fully engaged yeah
that's really great i while you were in
a euphoric hole yesterday i was in a joe
rogan hole because what i don't know why
i just like have gotten gone down to joe
rogan hall i can watch the episodes on
my tv and he has so many interesting
guests on the episodes are three hours
and
i've just been watching so many episodes
there's so many interesting factoids and
conversations being had over there and
it was really like
towards the end of the night i was like
i've got to switch gears because i'm
just like in a podcast wormhole well you
know it must be good there's a reason so
many people watch it so many people it
is so crazy how many people i heard one
of his episodes recently got 40 million
listens
40 million i'm so jealous imagine if we
had 40 million listeners like the change
we could enact yeah
uh jealous yeah it's pretty sickening
stuff so that was fun then i just read a
little bit there was no tv mandatory tv
on last night so that was really a gift
a joy
a joy though the bachelor was on for
those who
for those who participate
happy for those who are still inflicting
themselves with torture
once a week yeah like the snatcher and
there's a new episode of the snatcher i
like to i would watch a bachelor just to
hear
from the snatcher no i hear that
wholeheartedly you know but then i can
also just facetime her and she's been
picking up recently
access having like direct access to the
snatcher is
kind of one of the best perks of our job
would you agree a hundred percent it's
so special
oh and you know today is the four-year
anniversary of the first time we met
lauren elizabeth i saw in your story
what a fun fact
i know tnn was born four day four years
ago tnn was
perhaps like i don't know
born in utero the egg fertilized
oh yeah oh yeah
um so i wish i had more to add to our
pre-show conversation but i literally i
had a dream about euphoria like i'm so
in euphoria my dreams are so influenced
these days by whatever i'm consuming
like it's so annoying like even when i
was reading the pregnancy book it was
just like pregnancy statistics in my
dream like everything it's
it's really frustrating you have to
actually like curate what you watch
because it's like what do i want to
spend eight hours with tonight while i
drink no
you really cannot escape your dreams i
know like you know if you have something
going on in your life that you're like
like when i have something stressful
going on like i really try not to think
about it like i compartmentalize it push
it to the back of my brain but once my
eyes closed at night like i'm forced to
confront like the demons inside and when
my eyes are closed i
see you for what you truly are which is
ugly nice reference
thanks so much well we have some
interesting stories for you today so i
think we could just
jump right in on a bash plus we have
deer toasters which i'm so excited like
what's going on with bauble did we get
an update you'll let me know i don't
believe we have any updates today and
that's not on us that's on the listeners
if you come to us for advice and then
once we solve your problems you're like
done with us that is hella disrespectful
please write in do things get worse they
get better like we're just dying here no
one writes us back i don't know i i
that's human nature i have to respect of
course it's like you don't go and leave
a yelp review for a restaurant you
really love right or it's like you don't
like pray so hard when you're going
through amazing times
i know you know sometimes like when i do
pray it's only when i'm like you need
something
right and then i always have to
apologize i'm like i'm so sorry god that
like i have been such an animal like
when things are going good like i
totally forget about you but when i'm in
dark times like i turn to you and that's
not cool of me and i always promise that
i'm going you'll be able to change but i
don't i do think that god understands
that was something that i i i believe
that i learned like in uh bible classes
tour classes that like god knows that's
what we do
and he okay he's an understanding queen
that makes me feel so much better
because like whenever i pray like the
first thing out of my mouth is like i'm
so sorry i haven't been here for you
like i know shit's going really well for
me and that's really uncool and i
promise like i'm gonna keep talking
in the good times too yeah so i think
that's what happens with your toasters
like it's just human nature to only
reach out when you need something when
you need help of course of course of
course okay right it's like customer
service nobody writes an email like i
had such a great experience thanks
totally
totally um but yes dear toasters is
today if you have an update please write
us in like we need to hear from you yes
we do so without further ado
it is time for the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
movement always use protection we all
know this but sometimes we forget while
we're doing the thing we love the most
scrolling on our phones binging our
favorite shows or inevitably spending
lots of time in front of our digital
screens and movement is here to make
sure you're practicing safe scrolling
with their best selling ever scroll blue
light filtering glasses so if you have
not gone on the blue light glasses game
and you're spending as much time on tick
tock watching tv on your computer as i
am like you really need to protect your
eyes it'll help you sleep so much better
there's so many benefits
to blue light glasses because blue light
can be super harsh on our eyes and some
studies show that too much exposure to
blue light can lead to disrupting sleep
patterns other health effects and that's
why movement ever scrolls are game
changers your eyes will thank you
they're crafted with top tier materials
movement ever scrolls filters out ninety
percent of the most intense blue light
rays and feature anti-glare glasses for
elevated comfort they're designed
in-house of
out of their california headquarters and
they're available in a wide variety of
modern fashion forward frames um so when
i get in bed at like well i'm always in
bed when i officially start to go to bed
it's like eight o'clock and then i go to
bed at like 10 30 11 and for those two
and a half hours i am always wearing my
blue light glasses because i'm scrolling
tik tok i'm watching tv i'm on my
computer i'm like editing stuff you
always have to be wearing your blue
light glasses and it really makes such a
difference like you will feel a visible
difference in the way you sleep and just
the way you feel overall
so if you want to protect your eyes with
style that doesn't break the bank then
join the movement and get 15 off today
with free shipping and free returns by
going to mvmt.com
toast again that's
com mvmt.com toast for 15 off plus free
shipping and free returns and your eyes
will just genuinely thank us yeah and
it's one thing to be like addicted to
your phone you can't help it but you can
help wearing blue light glasses and also
for our headache girlies out there it
really it does help if you are
constantly looking at blue light too
that's so true to protect your eyes
okay our first story a bit of an update
from um a story from yesterday bob
saget's passing
bob saget was quote unresponsive and not
breathing and had no pulse in a 911
audio call that was released on monday
so bob saget was found not breathing and
had no pulse when he was found
unresponsive in his hotel room in
florida a security guard from the ritz
carlton in orlando alerted authorities
on sunday at 4 pm after an employee
found saggett lying in his hotel bed the
orange county sheriff's office said
quote we have an unresponsive guest in
the room my officer is telling me
there's no pulse the guard said in the
9-1-1 call obtained by the post
unresponsive not breathing and no pulse
according to a death investigation
report the 65 year old comedian was
found lying on his back in bed with his
left arm across his chest and his right
arm resting on the bed
also cops um suspect that he
uh suffered a heart attack or a stroke
in the hotel room according to the daily
mail so
got it because like some of the
information that's coming out it's like
more details but it's making it more
confusing so like no foul play no
evidence of drug use so what like a
perfectly healthy looking 65 year old
man doesn't just drop dead right so this
is some more of the information it
always is surprising to me that 9-1-1
calls
become
public public i couldn't agree more and
like sometimes they come up on my tick
tock like the most disturbing 9-1-1
calls in the last 10 years and they're
so invasive and so heartbreaking and i
just don't feel like they should be
shared like have you ever heard the um
the 911 call from when demi lovato
overdosed i don't think so
it's so cryptic and they're like they
they tell the ambulance not to put the
sirens on so it's like not to draw any
attention to demi's house it's like it's
just so cryptic and it's like a moment
in time and you feel like you're there i
just don't like listening to them yeah
and there's also a tv show that's like
all about
9-1-1 calls yeah it's like
over-dramatized
like crazy [ __ ] that's happened yeah
but it seems to be a popular show
yeah i guess that's just you know
something that is fact um but still it's
surprising especially when it's like a
celebrity or someone that you know and
it just feels like extra personal and
invasive totally but i guess it's just
part of the story it's facts and it's
out there
yeah so
a heart attack
potentially possibly it's looking like
that or a stroke
oh that is just so crazy so crazy and so
sad apparently his family was like
hadn't heard from him all day so they
sent
um
hotels the security guard up to the room
to see what was happening
well now all these um like tributes are
pouring in and you know what like i
guess a lot of bob's friends went over
to his house yesterday to be with his
wife like john mayer was there jeff ross
was there john stamos and like the
paparazzi like i know it's the world we
live in but like they're standing
outside while like john stamos is
embracing his wife kelly and it just
feels so wrong like so so wrong to be
seeing that right i saw that
that they were that the paparazzi were
there for that as well and it's like
the world will nothing will go on if
those pictures are not published no and
i didn't even want to click them i
didn't want it to be like this is
popular so we should do this more
yeah yeah no i didn't click them either
but it's just like even if it's popular
what what did you like what where's the
line like where is the line it's crazy
yeah but overall all of the tributes
that have come out about him are so
overwhelmingly sweet and like it seems
like he was just incredibly beloved by
fans and colleagues and it's a major
loss
yeah jimmy kimmel did a really really
nice one on his show last night um and
of course all the full house people
are um are speaking out and it's just
it's the craziest thing like i just
can't i still can't believe it like
shock and disbelief
shock and disbelief also do you see mary
kate and ashley spoke out also which is
surprising for them just because they're
they don't really do that yeah
and they haven't been associated with
the show for like 20 years right
so i thought their their uh message was
lovely i thought so too
now for our next story a little celeb
breakup news delaila bell hamlin and
boyfriend ayal booker have broken up
this is surprising yeah shocking delaila
bell and her boyfriend ayal have broken
up after two years of dating a source
confirmed to page six on monday the
daughter of lisa renner and harry hamlin
ended her relationship with the love
island star just before the new year so
she could begin 2022 with a fresh start
the insider told page six it was
important to her that 2022 could be a
fresh start and right now she wants to
be single and focus on her career last
year she experienced some difficult
times but she's come out to the other
side stronger than ever and is happy
enjoying time with friends and family as
well as looking positivity to the future
positively i assume is what i assume
that was there sick that s-i-c
parentheses
um i was really surprised by this
because for me like when they first got
together i'm like who is this guy like
it seems so random but they've been so
tried and true for so long to me they
were so otp i never even thought about
them like i'm like oh they're just
married
no i would like i was waiting for
engagement news next and
even the fact that he was on the show i
don't follow her so closely but every
time i do he seems like such a solid
partner for her and vice versa and even
when she shared like her story a few
months ago about her experience this
year with her health issues like ayal is
really like the common denominator and
really being there for her through all
of that so
this obviously you know there's always
more to the story and people share the
good stuff but this was just surprising
and sad because i really surprisingly i
feel like although you know it they're
going their separate ways like this was
a love story
yeah and they were really well suited
for each other and they found each other
on like totally opposite ends of the
earth opposite like ends of the industry
like you never i don't even know how
they could have connected i think she
dm'd him she saw him on love island
right and he's british she went to
london for so long like i'm just really
surprised yeah me too
but i know she's had like a really tough
year and i just want happiness for
delaila bell right i agree and if that's
not a all then it's not a all but i
thought that it's not all but i thought
it was that's all i'm saying
no i didn't think it was like i knew it
was and like i can't explain how little
they lived in my mind only because like
they were so solid like i never had to
worry about them yeah
i agree crazy
crazy we'll be curious to see who they
date next but well that's the other
thing like delilah bell is like
epitome of like young hollywood
socialite
so gorgeous
young
everything of the sort so
i would like she could honestly i could
see you're dating jacob lordy next yeah
but everyone's like in this one pool
that we keep pulling from right right
okay you know by the way we haven't
really even spoken about how olivia jade
and jacob belordy are rumored to be
dating they were spotted like twice
okay i heard that and then it left my
mind and now it's entering again so it
sounds like i'm hearing it for the first
time but i know that i've already heard
that and i completely ship
i ship so wholeheartedly
do you like love him even more now
because of euphoria
no jackie he is the villain like not
only is he the villain he's so [ __ ]
evil no
that and he's actually an extremely
talented actor he's so believably evil
believable that i don't even think he's
hot in the show like i'm like this man
is a disgrace to humanity oh my god
awful like really [ __ ] evil
oh i really wasn't expecting that
but he's an amazing actor but now i'm
like looking at him through a lens i'm
like i honestly don't think you're that
cute like if you can act that good at
being evil maybe you are evil i don't
know i don't think so
it's just like the show is really not i
don't know if it's designed to make you
attracted to him because he has all
these great shirtless scenes lots of sex
scenes but it's just not working for me
because i'm like but you're evil maybe
it's just because i have a conscious
like a good moral compass so is there
anyone from the show that you're now
like obsessed with who you weren't
before
maddie okay so i haven't
gone on instagram and like followed and
stalked the people yet because i don't
want to spoil it for myself so i don't
even know her real name but her name is
maddie in the show
oh and here's the one thing about about
um
euphoria
okay so i knew nothing about the show
but because of tick tock like i knew
every single song and i don't know like
did euphoria make these songs popular on
tik tok or were they popular on tick
tock and then euphoria put them in the
show i really feel like euphoria like if
your song gets on euphoria that's the
new like trl for real like every single
song i heard on tick tock this don't
feel like friday night
you know like all those tick tock ones
yep
and all these like moments have gone
viral on tik tok and to hear them in
context in the show as verse like
someone on you know tick tock lip
singing i know nobody likes me because
i'm dressed like a hooker
no wait i know i'm not supposed to be
here because none of you like me and i'm
dressed like a hooker but i just wanted
to say congratulations and now i know
the context it was that chili oh there
was a chili cook-off in the show
but it wasn't giving like americana
feels like it was giving it
wasn't performing
no there was this carnival that was like
extremely dark like it wasn't i used to
love going to the carnival like the
rides the food this was like the worst
carnival ever like everyone was going
through traumatic [ __ ] at the carnival
yeah but also i don't know if like as an
adult you go like you just see things
differently or if the carnival industry
has changed because the few times i've
gone like as a grown woman it's like
really
nothing of the sort wow that makes me so
sad i can't remember the last time i
went to a carnival as a grown woman but
maybe i shouldn't because the memories
of like us maybe once or twice a year
going to a carnival and like doing the
rides are probably like some of my most
fond wonderful precious memories yeah i
don't know i i i want to believe that
those maybe i just haven't gotten to any
good carnival the last carnival i went
to was like summer 2019 i went out in
the hamptons to a carnival well the
hamptons one is supposed to be a good
one so if you didn't like it um it had
its ups and downs and there was
literally no one there
what yeah nobody respects the art of
carnivaling anymore no it's right like
the idea is always a good one oh my god
and i was [ __ ] my pants on the
ferris wheel like i
and it wasn't even that bit like it was
i do not [ __ ] with ferris wheels no i
think that they are the worst ride i
would literally rather go on an upside
down roller coaster five times and even
the one that like swings from
[Music]
everyone else did that i did not do it i
that's just like i'm too fearful for
stuff like that
of course
yeah i and
i actually i only went to six flags once
in my life i think
i actually don't think i've ever been to
a six vlogs when i was in high school um
one of the years that i was in high
school we won the like uh
what was that
like color war for all the greats yeah
and oh and you got a day uh and we got a
day at six flags and i had never been
like on a roller coaster and i just
always assumed like i would never do it
but i was waiting online i was like i'll
make the decision when i get to the
front and the line was so long that by
the time i got to the front i was like
well now i have to do this or outside
just wasting my whole day oh yeah so
then i did it and then i did a million
times and then i was it an upside down
roller coaster
oh i've never like i don't test god like
that no no i will never i knew that day
i would never do it again but i just
like i leaned in for the day
no i'm so proud of you and i'm so glad
nothing happened to you but actually
like i will never like i don't trust
roller coasters not a conspiracy
theorist but like there's just a guy
running it who like doesn't care he's
like getting paid no money he's like
[ __ ] this job [ __ ] these people he
doesn't even check if we're secured like
absolutely not absolutely not i
completely agree and then you hear like
some of the craziest stories of things
that go down at amusement parks or
carnivals and it's just like and it's
like it's because there's a 17 year old
kid who just like smoked pot and is now
running this event a hundred percent
it's back to jacob lordy and
olivia jade so happy for them i really
hope it's real i agree i agree okay it's
honestly just like science like two of
the most gorgeous people in the world
like they have to scientifically at
least try going out yeah that i think
that's what they're trying to do
just following science yeah
our next story kendall jenner is
responding to the accusation that her
wedding guest dress was inappropriate
back in november do you remember when
kendall was a guest at a wedding and she
wore this cut out black dress and
everyone was like if this girl was at my
wedding like she would be
gone well yeah but here's the thing if
this girl was at my wedding and she was
some [ __ ] from high school like she
would be gone if it was kendall jenner
at my wedding i would be grateful she
showed up and she could wear whatever
the [ __ ] she wants agreed well
she responded to an instagram comment
someone said inappropriate outfit at a
wedding kendall i'm embarrassed for you
and someone else wrote if the bride
herself doesn't give a [ __ ] why do you
care then the bride commented said tell
them she looks stunning and i loved it
and then kendall commented avi asked for
your approval in advance to we love a
beach wedding
well that's the thing like when you're
really close with the bride like you
have to send what you're wearing to the
bride
you do even if you're not a bridesmaid
kendall was a bridesmaid they all wore
different dresses and then changed oh
so like you get approval from the bride
even if you're not even if there's no
bridesmaids and you're just like really
close to the bride like you always send
the picture like you just every you know
no one no none of my really close
friends showed up to my wedding wearing
a dress that i hadn't seen before
same but because they were all had to
get their dresses like bridesmaid
approved no i'm saying not even
bridesmaids like just people at the
wedding they're like we're sending me
pictures like i'm wearing this am i cute
i don't know
if no one was sending me pictures that
like
if you're that close we are you're a
bridesmaid no not for me
i don't know and like if kendall
jenner's coming your wedding like
you know you know yeah i don't know i
don't think
you know if you're a celebrity like you
do fittings whatever i don't think like
you necessarily have to send a picture
of your dress but i do think if you're a
kendall jenner like and you're going to
a wedding you really can wear whatever
you want it's just like and you are a
bridesmaid so like this girl knew what
the dress was right that's just like a
perk of being like an a-list
supermodel you know you no one's gonna
tell you what to wear
right so yes i guess in the context of a
normal person you know a regular wedding
at a regular venue
yes if someone showed up in this all the
parents would be clutching their pearls
of course but this is like extenuating
circumstances this is not the real world
like you know i agree if someone from
like
at your wedding who is not kendall
jenner
came wearing this dress like becky becky
from the redheads showed up wearing this
dress she would be the talk of the town
the parents the grandparents
quaking quaking agreed but this is not
the real world like this is like a
fictional this is like a fashion show
when your best friends are kendall and
and haley bieber like
everyone's just walking the runway and
it's not the wedding rules don't apply
yeah like how stupid that this even
needed to be a dress like it was a
private wedding like [ __ ] off
yeah but i did think it was funny it was
just a funny conversation oh and by the
way if i looked even one iota like
kendall jenner i would wear that dress
everywhere and no one could say anything
to me about it 100
so yeah
are you ready for our next story
i am
lily james says she reached out to
pamela anderson about pam and tommy with
no response she said i was hopeful so
lily james is in this new hulu mini
series called pam and tommy which is
about pamela anderson and tommy
lee
lee yes i know him because his son's on
the hills reboot
right yeah he's actually great brandon
the son yeah i remember him um and so
have you seen the trailer for the show
i have not
her transformation it's not lily james
i've seen pictures of her it's crazy she
sat like in makeup for hours every
single day but it really like really
bears no resemblance to lily james okay
this is the other weird thing that i
just put together i was looking at my
phone tommy lee is now currently married
to brittany ferland former viner yeah
crazy crazy turn of events i wonder
that will make it into the show probably
not no but i did she looked amazing and
i need to watch a trailer because she
really transformed really transformed
and i also wanted to know if your
opinion before i get to the story if
your opinion of lily james has changed
since down to nappy
okay so
yes because
of all the characters that came through
on downton abbey
rose played by lily james was my
favorite and yes i am biased because she
ended up marrying someone jewish and
loved him wholeheartedly and didn't care
about the trials and tribulations that
were gonna be facing them spoilers um
and i loved her
but like before that my only real you
know knowledge of lily james was this
whole dominic west thing you know and i
know she'd done other acting before but
i hadn't seen much of it um but yes yes
yes to answer your question in a long
winded way yes things have changed
things have changed i respect lily james
i can't separate the lily from the rose
that's good that's good i agree i feel
like she brought a lot of herself to
rose and rose was very lovable therefore
lily must be lovable and to be honest
before i watch downton abbey i didn't
really consider lily james like a
serious actress the only things i really
had known her in was like cinderella
which i never even saw which was like a
flop
and i think that's it so i never
remember mia the scene never saw it
never saw it and to be honest i wouldn't
categorize like that as like a serious
acting
yeah
also the movie yesterday which was i
thought a horrible never saw it horrible
awful
but now i categorized her as like a
serious oscar-contending actress yes and
now
only talented actors and actresses get
involved in downton abbey 100 and now
with pam and tommy i think she's going
down that road even further anyways to
get to the point in a cover story for
porter that was published on monday she
said that she reached out to pamela
anderson ahead of shooting the series in
hopes of having her involved in the
project however lily says she didn't get
a response quote i was really hopeful
that she would be involved i wish it had
been different my sole intention was to
take care of the story and to play
pamela authentically i was very hopeful
that we would be in touch right up until
we started filming
hmm that's interesting because
so it's when it comes
right when it comes to a biopic
i really need authorization yeah and
when no like for me i wanted to see king
richard and then knowing like venus and
serena were like heavily involved made
me want to see it even more yeah even
the like it's actually a double-edged
sword because if someone's involved in
their own biopic they're obviously going
to be biased in what gets shown how they
get portrayed
um but then if they're not involved it's
like how do you know that any of this
happened how do you know what was going
through her mind even if she said one
thing how do you know she what she felt
privately i i think that
i mean i'm gonna i plan on watching this
but i would imagine that the show
suffers if it's not
and if they're not involved it's
literally called pam and tommy and it's
about like one of the craziest it's
mostly about like the sex tape
got it so
if you uh it feels knowing this now it's
like a little bit weird that that they
don't have her involvement
it's not like even her approval right
right no it doesn't bode well it's
giving like a lifetime original movie
no but in lifetime original movies
depending on who's it's about a lot of
times the celebrities is involved like i
think janet jackson's about to do one
wendy williams just did one
uh i don't know if a lot of times this
like you know obviously like the harry
and megan one harry and megan weren't
involved yeah i once watched one about
anna nicole smith i can't imagine
it was posthumously approved or her camp
yeah no proved it so
anyways the show does look really good
but that is an interesting factoid it's
a little bit of like a a downer
for sure
right
are you ready for our fifth and final
story it's a twofer a bit of um what
would we call this a bit of tv news
okay
i got a lot of comments that when i
podcast from home my final story like
breaks the eardrum so i'm gonna take a
step back okay yeah and a few tips
because yesterday we were on point but
you weren't hearing it someone suggested
you take your headphones out
and then
now she can't hear me
you listen to me three two one it's the
final story
[Music]
[Music]
and that's a magic number
it's getting better every day
okay okay it's getting better every day
don't you think
that's all you can ask for yeah
fifth and final story two parts some tv
news first emily and paris has been
renewed for two more seasons at netflix
seasons three and four but the society
never got a second chance okay but the
society never got a second chance okay
like netflix could not make news about
anything without me comparing it to the
society
i totally agree
and
i'm happy for the emily in paris girlies
happy for lily collins because she
really seems to like embrace being emily
wait okay did you see
that when it was announced that rooney
mara was going to be playing audrey
hepburn everyone on the internet it was
kind of like how when beatty feldstein
yes got fanny bryce everyone was like
lily michelle and when rooney mara got
audrey hepburn everyone was like but
what about lily collins and i had never
even thought about it but then seeing
pictures of them of them side by side
like they are
queens they are twins but also like lily
collins and rooney mara are twins too
like they all look like audrey hepburn
right but i think like the consensus on
the internet was like if there ever was
an audrey hepburn buyer pit but
fire pick
biopic it would be played by lily
collins hands down and what people on
the internet were saying which i
actually really agreed with was until
emily and paris i think i would have
considered lily collins to be like a
pretty serious actress like 100
i saw that movie she did on like her
well not her but like the characters
battle with anorexia it was so
dark very difficult to watch but
extremely well done by lily and i just
think she's like cheapened her whole
brand i'm sure she's making a lot of
money and is having a lot of commercial
success with emily in paris but i no
longer have her in my category of like
ghosts to the oscars
1 000 i would have said the exact same
thing the person who plays emily in
paris doesn't also play
audrey doesn't also play you know holly
go lightly at tiffany's like it just
can't happen and i think probably her
doing emily and paris overall is the
bigger better move so i i don't think
she's like regretting anything
but i you can't do both it precludes her
from being audrey hepburn who's
literally like the most serious
glamorous
female actress like of all time yeah
so um i hadn't really even thought of
lily collins for for the role but then
when i when someone said i was like oh
duh yeah
i agree and i'm glad they went with
rooney because she's
across the board
yeah and you know what like lily collins
should be punished for giving us a
million
so will you be watching seasons three
and four yeah probably because i'm like
a hater who loves to hate on things and
i do a podcast like unfortunately
requires me to watch trash like that
and those are the sacrifices i make yeah
also someone was like i saw people were
like jack you have to watch emily and
powers like you would love it i've seen
season one like i i've seen enough
i no you really don't need to see it by
any means i've got it
you know yeah you've got it i've got her
number
memorized and i just don't think it's
going to get better for me
no especially like i don't know
now that you're pregnant and becoming a
mom i do think like there are some
things you can't do anymore one of them
is watching emily in paris i agree i
think i have to make some changes and i
think that they are actually natural
changes that i've been like on my way
towards but i do think like my content
plate like i'm getting a different plate
this is not my play this is no longer my
plate but i think that's what's great
about you and i because it's your plate
and they all have a different plate and
all of our listeners have different
plates so why should our place be the
same so now we're covering maternity
books and euphoria 100
and our second follow-up to the story
because i didn't think either one of
them was strong enough to strongly
on its own is that white lotus season
two at hbo has casted aubrey plaza so i
forgot that white lotus is like going to
be
season a seasoned show which makes sense
they'll bring like new people to the
island yeah but i'm still unclear like
if anyone from season one returns
it is rumored that jennifer coolidge is
returning but h well i think that was
has yet to um
confirm confirm that but so aubrey plaza
will be playing someone who um is on a
trip with her husband and his friends
which sounds like really good
yeah which sounds like a torturous
experience yeah a vacation with your
husband and his friends yeah
aubrey plaza is great i think that'll be
good yeah no this this sounds really
good i mean even though i wasn't
enamored with white lotus i enjoyed
i enjoyed the time i spent watching it
it was very aesthetically pleasing and
it made me chuckle and it made me really
want to go to hawaii i've never been
i've never been either it's literally
the number one place i want to go like
on my the list is short but number one
is hawaii
and i we were supposed to go for our
honeymoon which just never happened so
you're here sister i don't think we're
going anytime soon now that you know
life is about to pick up
yeah so um let me know how it is i'll
watch season two me too
hopefully no one takes any more dumps
like that was just a little extreme for
me
you know i liked it
i know you did because you're a dump
girly
i'm a big dump
um well let's dive into your toasters
which is our advice segment if you ever
want to write in dear toasters gmail.com
is the email and we will read your
prompt on air anonymously of course you
can change people's names we will
protect you serve you and hopefully give
you the best advice and dear toasters is
brought to you by fit on
fit on is the number one premium free
fitness app and it's redefining the
workout experience the fit on workouts
are always free to use and they offer
workouts for any fitness level and
they're super easy to follow you can
access over a thousand workouts anytime
anywhere and they have workouts just as
short as five minutes so there's no
excuse to skip a workout especially if
you're working from home you pop it up
it's super easy to access do five ten
minute workout you just feel better
knowing you didn't skip but there's
always something for you on fit on and
they already have over 10 million people
who use it so you know it's
as the kids say busting
um they also
they also have a wide variety of workout
styles like cardio strength training
toning pilates yoga so whatever you're
in the mood for whether it's super high
energy more low key
they've got you covered
you can take classes alongside
celebrities like gabrielle union
julianne huff and more and they've more
than 350 000 5 star views and no
equipment or gym membership is required
which is great super low lift for you
just get it done if you're busy you have
kids you have work
take 10 minutes for yourself 30 minutes
for yourself get it done it's free you
can join over 10 million people getting
their fit on work out for free anytime
anywhere text toast to 64 000 to join
fit on for free again text toast
t-o-a-s-t to 64 000 that's toast to 64
000. wonderful thank you claude so much
now i'm so excited to get into deer
toasters
it's a pleasure
okay oh no oh bruno is excited for dear
toasters too okay he's being a little
crazy because the doorbell just rings
okay ready hello claudia and jackie i'm
an og breath or slash toaster love you
guys the pups the steens the podcast etc
thank you
let me make my font a little bigger so i
don't have a bobble again
okay i need help asap i've been in a
very healthy and happy relationship with
my boyfriend for almost 10 years for
context we got together in high school
and now we're in our mid-20s we moved in
together two years ago to another state
and i'm so happy our 10-year anniversary
is in june and i'm fully expecting a
proposal sometime then
i mean it'll be a full decade by then we
talk about houses and babies which is
always meant with an agreement but when
talking about getting engaged in actual
wedding stuff he clamps up i'm
full-blown mad about it is that crazy
part of me is like we know we want to be
together so what's the big deal but the
other part of me is like why the [ __ ]
won't you just talk with me talk with me
about marriage
i brought it up and he says he just
doesn't want any pressure which i get
like pressure but also i asked him if
he's against marriage and he said no so
please advise sincerely a confused
toaster i mean 10 years is a hell a long
time and 10 years is a long time to not
be able to like have have that
conversations about really important
things like that so yeah
i mean if the relationship is good and
like you know
it's hard like you are so committed to
each other so it's like it shouldn't
really make that much of a difference
but i do find that like men just put off
like engagement wedding talking about it
like like it's this big taboo thing and
like and then they do it and it's just
like i should have done this so long ago
yeah like for me i think about this a
lot how like you know there's so many
guys who don't want to commit to
marriage but they're happy being in a
long-term relationship they just don't
want to commit to marriage and i really
genuinely think that's so [ __ ] stupid
and moronic there's literally nothing
different about being in a marriage than
being and just like boyfriend girlfriend
who lived together like it's so stupid
no here's here's what's different it's
not a commitment you've already made the
commitment here's what's different is
that you're not constantly like
tense and fighting about when are we
gonna get married are we gonna get
engaged and and you
even if the man has felt secure in the
relationship the whole time like
the
woman now like that to take that off of
your shoulders especially 10 years worth
even though like it was high school
is
you know a a weight lifted
yeah and i feel like this guy's just
taking advantage of like your guys being
really comfortable together
and maybe that just has to do with you
guys like getting into some sort of a
rut being together for so long not
really progressing
so
i don't know i hate an ultimatum but
they're hella effective they are
effective they happen for a reason and
if this is what you want and
you like want to take the next step i
want to think you've been incredibly
patient
and i think you are well within your
rights to start
making some
some ultimatums or just like be
aggressive in the conversation like the
fact that he's such a weenie like i
don't want to talk about it like
pressure like what the [ __ ] up like
seriously yeah no that's that's a little
bit of a red flag honestly
yeah because honestly there is really no
nothing
scary about marriage like i understand
people who aren't ready to have kids
like that's a huge thing but i don't
understand people in hella long-term
relationships who are like nervous about
getting married like that's not a thing
like not at all yeah
i agree i think he's gotta he's gotta
mature and sometimes you [ __ ] or get off
the pod and sometimes you've gotta push
and it's and if no one wants to be that
person no one ever fancies themselves as
like the girl who's going to like you
know
nag you for a ring right but only
synthesizes about like forcing or like
it's not romantic it's not romantic but
it's real life if this is your man's and
this is the person that you want to be
with then you've got to do some pushing
and
i i
i'm sorry
agreed but it's also as jackie said like
a big red flag
yeah but not i mean it i think it's also
just like
can be in their nature to just think
that that marriage is so much more than
it is when i think a lot of the time
afterwards it's just sort of
this weightlifted it's a relief and you
focus on other things afterwards as
opposed to like when are we getting
engaged
right and like yes planning a wedding is
the stressful part but marriage is not
like there's
especially if you're with the right
person of course like relationships are
hard but they're hard whether you're
married or not 100 and i'm giving advice
to this girl based on the fact that it
sounds like this is the right person
because you're not with the worst you're
not happily with the wrong person for 10
years for 10 years yeah you move to a
whole other state together and like have
the best life right so if this this
seems to be the right person and we've
gotta we've got to make it work for you
yes all right next up
all right i need advice for my loving
sister my sister-in-law mary has been
dating her boyfriend jerry for about
seven years we come from a pretty
conservative family and they just
recently decided to move in together no
one thinks that's weird but here's where
the problem comes in jerry asked
permission to marry her four years ago
now and never proposed or gave any
reasoning as to why he never did she's
been dress shopping three times talks
about getting married all the time she
even had a wedding plan for june that
never happened
mary gave jerry an ultimatum well and
said if he doesn't propose by the end of
2021 then she's moving out it's 2022
still no ring everyone sees that they're
unhappy together after they had a
yelling fight in front of everyone over
the holidays mind you they're about
eight years apart and he always talks
down to her and that's just the
beginning of all their problems but we
don't know what to do do we just leave
it alone and pretend we support this
awful relationship or do we say
something please we need your help and i
will be sure to send a follow-up if it
makes on the podcast that's why we chose
this one thank you guys for giving me
something to look forward to every week
love a devoted toaster
okay this is this is weird jerry seems
like a problem
yeah not only does she talk down to her
he's postponed getting engaged for four
years let her lets her go wedding dress
shopping plans fake weddings knowing
full well that he's not gonna propose
this is emotional manipulation and abuse
and i think he's toxic and i think
you're well within your rights as a
sister-in-law to say something
sister-in-law
yes oh and okay regardless i and if you
if you're writing into us you clearly
like you're close you're close and you
care a lot so i would say like also all
of those things are
not good but they're also like kind of
vague like we're gonna get engaged oh
okay so like you blah blah blah but like
she asked the parents permission like
that's
right
she said they're really conservative end
of 2021 and 2021 has ended and now it's
time for mary walk the walk she's gotta
walk the walk
but you can't force someone you can't
force someone and also it's like
if you always think the engagement's
right around the corner it's like wow
i'm really gonna break up with you of
seven years because of the difference of
two weeks
you know yeah but he they said end of
2021 and that's a very clear marker i
know but it's hard to especially when he
was ready to do it four years ago i know
but like this is mary's life
yeah but mary's also okay beyond okay
let's see what's happening tomorrow but
jerry's also a piece of [ __ ] in a person
jerry in a perfect world you say end of
2021 and it doesn't happen and then on
january 1st 2022 mary packs her bags and
goes
but it's hard it's easier said than done
and seven years at seven years and the
last four of really thinking like you're
going to get married to this person it's
a lot to wrap your head around
so i think you course but i think if
mary's coming to this girl for advice
i would tell this girl to urge her to
make moves she talked the talk it's time
to walk the walk yeah and you know what
walking the walk even if you're bluffing
like it could it you have a closer
chance to getting what you're looking
for as opposed to if you're not bluffing
he lets you go is that the man you want
to marry right so if you're talking to
mary
i would say i would help her try and
wrap her head around the fact that this
could be it and that her last
effort should be
bluff central and walk out the door
yeah it's a win-win with the bluff of
course you'll be sad at the end but if
you leave it might get him off his ass
to do something and if you leave and he
doesn't do anything who the [ __ ] would
want to marry that guy especially when
he talks down to you and is mean yeah
and he just doesn't seem like
the greatest guy
yeah it would be a blessing in disguise
years down the road
it's just it's easy for us to say that i
just know for mary like she loves jerry
i know
mary
i don't know where people come up with
these names but like literally mary and
jerry
mary and jerry haven't gotten married
mary and jerry getting married oh my god
that is so funny best of luck mary and
jerry yeah you just have to really be
there for her and obviously give her
like this you know strong tough love
advice but also support her because her
whole world is not turning out to be
what she thought it was going to be
yeah all right our third and final deer
toasters hi cloudy and jackie i feel
ridiculous writing this but i want to
see if you can give me any advice i met
my best friend sarah in college five
years ago right before the pandemic hit
i went back to her home state with her
for the first time while i was there i
met her brother noah who's two years
younger than us and we instantly got
along great i had a little crush after
meeting him for the first time
but after going on more trips with her
and her family over the past two years
the crush has intensified we hang out a
bunch on these trips send each other
funny videos over text me occasionally
snapchat but i can't tell her for the
life of me i can't tell for the life of
me if he's into me or if we're just
friends i would never do anything if i
thought sarah would care but she
sometimes make jokes about us getting
married so i do think she'd be fine with
it the only thing is she can be a bit
intense so i haven't wanted to tell her
about me liking her brother in case he
doesn't like me back and it makes things
weird with how close i am to her and her
family noah and i don't see each other
often because we live in different
states but i am so curious if i'm
romanticizing this in my head or if he
actually feels the same way how do i go
about asking him how he feels without
making it awkward if he just sees us as
friends have if if he just sees us as
friends i'm more than fine with being
just friends but i can't help but wonder
if i'm delusional or not please help
xoxo and smitten toaster so i just want
to say i think the way you're going
about this is very smart like you cannot
go to sarah unless you know what's going
on with noah so now we have to find out
how the [ __ ] do we find out if noah
likes you because you know i can totally
see you making this up in your head like
it's happened to me before it happens to
a lot of people or it's like noah's the
kind of guy like oh my friend's sister's
in town like we're all together for the
weekend he's friendly and like yeah it's
flirting for sure but it's like no
please don't move across the country for
me like this isn't a great love of any
sort so it's it's a hard spot to be
anything you know in a perfect world you
you would ask your friend to find out if
he likes what i was saying but you can't
ask sarah no you'll be so awkward beyond
if he ends up no if he ends up liking
you like then it's cute and it was all
for a good cause but if he ends up not
liking you and like you told sarah that
like you like her brother but her
younger brother doesn't like you back
like that's mortifying i would never let
you do that mortifying and then you've
sullied the relationship with the whole
family and there's no coming back so
don't do that but i don't know why
towards the end of this i just started
to get the feeling that like noah's just
[ __ ] around
hmm
but that's not that's not a strong
enough case for me no i know no no we
need to leave
admission we need facts but i'm like
operating from a place of like it's not
going to be the answer that we want also
i'm a romantic and i'm thinking like
noah's the one what no he's like
snapchatting her and then like that's
what the kids do jackie
we need more background you need to get
more background on noah and his like
relationship
habits
yeah and maybe like the night is it a
different girl every weekend then you
were just that weekend you know
jackie that's me or is he like you know
writing love poems
in his journal every friday night
for his you know what sister's best
friend
maybe like asking sarah isn't that bad
of an idea because honestly that's the
only route i can think of like how do
you find out if a random boy likes you
like for real
what if next time you can't ask the only
link between you you can't ask that
person what if the next time you're all
together you just um
hook up
you like just go for it and then see
what he does after
yeah
i like that
i like want this to work out so badly i
don't know why i feel so hella invested
i feel so hesitant
oh no i'm like so hopelessly like i
think that this is the end for her like
noah and toaster for together forever
i would i would like that but i don't
know i'm just like getting
i'm just getting i have an idea
write us back in and give me noah's
phone number i'm gonna call him and i'm
just gonna say do you like susie or
whatever her name is he's gonna be like
who is this i'm like this is none of
your business i just need to know like
do you have feelings for rachel whatever
it's just hard because like you don't
live where noah lives so if you if you
went to have a conversation with him
about it it's like okay so we like each
other like are we gonna start dating are
we now like long distance it's it's
really
a lot and he's younger than you so he's
like immature
okay by the way
why don't you instead of just like
trying to hook up with him because you
only see him like twice a year why don't
you really like amp up the texting
snapchatting like almost to try to get
to the point where like you're talking
you know like that phase like the kids
are always talking about like talking
yeah like talking before bed when you
wake up
all the time facetime like why don't you
explore that and then if he's like
engaging with you and texting you first
then you'll know that there's an
interest but if he's just like waiting
for you to text him and like he's not
super responsive then unfortunately you
know like it's not happening
this is i don't know
i don't know why i'm like so
i'm against don't listen to jackie like
this is gonna happen for you it's just
if she if she met sarah five years ago
in college that would mean that they're
one year out of college and two and
noah's two years younger than them noah
is a sophomore in college so they're
like 20 and 22. noah's a sophomore
and
and he's going to be like our leading
man i don't think so he's going to risk
it all
well she came with the math you're 100
right
if this were like some people in their
30s
yeah i know he's in college he's [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying
i didn't think of that and then it's
just oh where i'm going on a family trip
with my weekend here's a girl i'm not
related to let's chat no
100 he doesn't like you i'm so sorry
that i led you along he does not like
you run for the hills he's a sophomore
in college like he's probably like
hazing a fraternity like swallowing
goldfish every night like no
no he might ev he might be a junior if
my math but still no
no
no
yeah put it on pause i i think i think
you need to let this simmer maybe if you
guys are all in the same position in a
few years like you
you don't want to date a junior in
college
when you're not in college and it seems
like you're already invested and i just
don't think see him getting to that
level and
i think
the best solution would be to move on
from this honestly
and maybe down the line sure i'm open to
whatever but right in the back pocket
for right now it's not worth ruining a
relationship with a great friend and her
family who takes you on trips
jackie is speaking facts left right and
center never listen to anything i say
she's 100 right i just okay i'm glad
that i worked through it because i
couldn't articulate like why i was just
not seeing it
i think maybe the fact that she like
gave him a pseudonym noah like really
got to me because i love the name now i
think it's like such a manly delicious
name i've never met a man named noah who
wasn't like a really stand-up honorable
man it's such an amazing name
so like that was her fault it's also
becoming incredibly popular right now
like i feel like in our class there
wasn't a lot of noah's you know no but
now i think there's a lot of noah's in
the class no and of course what comes to
mind is the man with the ark who really
saved all of civilization so and he was
an animal lover animal lover like the
face of peta so
i
i think i was really kind of blindsided
by her giving him that name yeah also
for my lack of judgment ryan gosling in
the notebook is noah
and so you just you see him as this
animal loving
romantic guy
and animal loving queen but instead he's
just a junior in college who's like
drinking from the punch bowl
no totally natty light for life exactly
saturdays are for the boys and he's just
like wearing a jersey all the time
showing his hairy armpits yeah it's not
gonna work
it's not gonna work
but maybe once he graduates yeah no
anything can happen in the future but
right now focus on yourself i think
maybe if you know if there is this sort
of thing between you and owen you pull
back that actually will obviously make
him like you more
there's no harm here
agreed amazing advice given by jackie um
wow i'm so glad that we parsed that out
for our
to wrap up the episode and you better
[ __ ] write us back with what happens
i don't care if it's in three years like
we will remember and we will celebrate
when you guys get engaged yeah and i do
think that that could happen it's just
not gonna happen right now nor should it
no one's gonna go noah's gotta like you
know see everyone else who's out there
and and having gotta get on the ark like
and and then you know realize that it
was you all along but he can't realize
it was you all along if we're in the
middle of the story
100 that's not how it works
sorry
um well i would like to thank everyone
who opened up to us in deer toasters
again if you ever want to write in
totally anonymously the email is dear
toasters gmail.com and we will do our
best to help you out and if we have
previously helped you out and you left
us high and dry do write us an email
letting us know how everything worked
out please
yes please do
and that
is our job couldn't be anyone else's
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast i wanted to share something
that i found so interesting first of all
two things one we have to bring back to
the society season two why isn't that
happening
two
um i so i was on spotify and i went to i
just saw our page and i saw you can
leave a review like stars yes spotify
just like launched that okay so i was
like oh okay like let me tap it to see
how the interface works like and you
know i'll give us a five star review and
spotify going right now spotify popped
up and said you have to listen to a few
episodes of this podcast before you can
leave a review how [ __ ] brilliant is
that oh my god the i.t team at spotify
needs a raise no that's like one of
those things that's a no-brainer it let
me do it because i listened to a bunch
on spotify i've never listened to our
show recently on spotify that is so cool
that like really stops like people on
reddit like flocking one star bombing
you right at least if you want to leave
a one star like you have to listen to a
few episodes and i would hope that if
you listen to a few episodes you
wouldn't want to leave one star anymore
oh my god thank you so much for sharing
that piece of technological innovation
with me right i just really warmed my
heart to see like tech doing some good
and
also a reminder you could leave five
stars on spotify if that's where you
listen we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasts can be found such
spotify itunes stitcher public radio
ihop radio cast box all the places
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning toast and leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are we hope you guys have an
amazing tuesday we'll see you tomorrow
for hump day and if you made it to the
end of this episode congratulations on
being a true toaster who values the
opinions of two beautiful stunning and
smart queens and to let us know that you
actually did in fact make it to the end
of the episode why don't you drop it why
don't you go drop an emoji on our most
recent instagram um to let us know that
you made it and how about that emoji be
how you
is there an ark emoji oh how about some
animals to honor the noble noah and his
ark so any animals you choose all the
animals
love you guys have an amazing day we'll
see you tomorrow goodbye